salah
exc
konica la cotisation pour les mettre sur
la plaque vraiment l'impression que
dimanche séoul qui soit
tout doit sembler simple et pourtant
même ces petites sardines et ses
coquillages sont finement préparé goûter
et validé par le grand chef cuisinier
le maître de cérémonie c'est cet homme
christophe leroy son plaisir sortir de
sa cuisine gastronomique pour créer
l'événement avec ses plats dans des
décors de rêve
son obsession le détail on le décrit
comme un metteur en scène les pieds nus
dans le sable le décor sur la plage les
costumes de cuisinier les sourires et
poignées de mains chaque détail est
construit l'a fait monter de toutes
pièces
rien n'est négligé tout doit sembler
naturel
justement c'est de donner l'impression
aux gens que les sardines ou les
coquillages ou les moules farcies
ils sortent de l'eau et tout ça donne
avec les flambeaux le feu de camp les
musiciens
mon truc qu'on rêve de vie 24 dès qu'ils
vivent ce soir 150 t penser dans le
moindre détail
oui même les moules même le produit à
moustiques qui a été passée à
lillehammer pourquoi qu'un espoir au
bord de l'eau le soir venu c'est
l'entrée en scène de la gastronomie dans
son restaurant le grand chef défend son
savoir faire
aucune improvisation n'est tolérée
commence alors le concert des
fourchettes et l'harmonie des casseroles
sont pas à table il se partage de vos
réflexes de semaine de découverte des
champignons
c'est un peu mou les pavés de lula a les
traits de tout sur moi je bosse te plaît
c'est bien c'est bien elles sont
superbes et violent comme ça un peu
moins de vaches agace encore les amendes
frei se demander tout à l'heure la
truffe râpé et les eaux
est ce qu'on a le temps de bien faire
quand on fait aussi vite en courant tout
le temps oui je pense que c'est une
façon de travailler notre métier fait
que c'est toujours dans l'urgence mais
finalement on travaille c'est une
impression on travaille pas vite
puisqu'on a l'habitude de travailler
comme ça
présentatrice mais dans la truffe fait
généreuse les généreux c'est justement
dans une situation d'urgence que
christophe leroy a inventé une recette
qu'il ne peut plus aujourd'hui retiré de
sa carte
la soupe de pommes de terre glacée aux
truffes
comme vatel en son temps avait imaginé
la crème chantilly dans sa cuisine en
dernière minute avant l'arrivée d'un
prestigieux invités louis xiv
christophe leroy lui a vu sa créativité
stimulée par un client célèbre faut
dépenser une idée avoue s'être cette
crise a oui c'est une idée que j'ai fait
il ya onze ans à l'occasion d'une âge
géniale idée pour faire avant de faire
son repas de mariage
gilles mahé mois dû faire dix couverts
comme ça dans une villa pour une fois
goûté ce que je faisais vous connaissez
pas et au dernier moment ils m'ont dit
qu'ils étaient 50 ans et c'est là que je
me suis dit retrouver des solutions de
toute urgence
il était 5 heures de l'après midi et
c'est là que j'ai dit on va faire une
soupe froide et c'est de la violence et
la soudaineté à glace et autres et j'ai
servi cette soupe tout mon entre eux ça
extraordinaire pour moi après c'était le
mariage le plat était un peu mis en
avant et il est devenu un peu votre la
force
enfin une soupe froide glacée avec des
truffes et du et des pommes de l'europe
c'est une petite photo avec une grande
célébrité ça ne peut pas faire de mal à
la notoriété c'est le jour ou jamais de
soigner son image
et vous qui aimez l'authentic le naturel
dans la nourriture on le retrouve pas
complètement la même si c'est le côté
photo qui peut vous paraître chauffe ça
fait partie de toutes faites qui existe
même une fête familiale on veut la photo
souvenir
moi je pense que c'est la même chose on
vit ça avec nos clients vous invitez
soit qu'ils sont invités et quelque part
qui sont tous ses amis c'est comme si je
faisais mon anniversaire ce soir
un anniversaire après lequel christophe
leroy a bien l'intention de récupérer de
nombreux cadeaux comprenez de multiples
contrats dans les villes à zélé yachts
de milliardaires pendant l'été
aujourd'hui il légua tous gratuitement
demain ils espèrent leur proposer une
réplique de sa fête à domicile mais
cette fois en présentant l'addition
il connaît bien son public et c'est donc
comment s'adresser à lui
oui
comment
jordi coucou on est là c'est moi qui
vous invite je suis un peu le premier
les invités donc ne m'oubliez pas au
moment de faire des fêtes chez vous un
petit peu oui c'est vrai que j'y pense
et puis il faut toujours animé quand on
est quand on est chef dans un endroit
comme saint tropez qui est un village où
les gens sont un peu blasés qui vivent
beaucoup de choses
ils sont sur le yacht ou dans la
propriété ils ont tendance à oublier un
peu tout donc mon rôle aujourd'hui il
est de de marquer le début de la saison
de ce côté du décor c'est un monde
merveilleux de l'autre c'est une autre
histoire
les gens sont dans le coup
des ventes et ce au tabac pour la teste
oui on n'a pas tout bien sûr
alors pourquoi vous avez vrai faux nez
dans la passe mais voilà [ __ ] y'a même
pas les cas ciel mais maintenant je suis
trop bien sûr ça va envoyer 5 180
invités à table
forcément ça rend nerveux qu'est ce qui
se passe là christophe bailly monf a
loupé énorme il devait mettre toutes les
entrées posé sur table les convives
arrivent et ne l'ont pas fait donc comme
vous je voyais ça complique la tâche et
on perd un quart d'heure dans le dîner
et le succès d'une fête c'est que le
dîner soit rapide
à qui était l'unique ce soit rapide qui
a été pris un risotto vallée relève le
fait prendre et cuisinier dans les
buffets et vous et je n'étais pas bon de
football pour faire une une comparaison
et toute ma famille on parlait cette
école football tous les dimanches et
tous donc j'étais un peu le petit con se
moquer parce que n'était pas mon foot
donc pas bon à l'école pas bon foot ça
faisait beaucoup et d'un seul coup j'ai
trouvé dans ses cuisines c'est cet état
d'esprit d'équipé à chaque service il ya
le feu il ya le coup de gueule et tout
est là je me suis dit ça y est j'ai
trouvé ma voie au bout de trois jours je
savais que j'étais dedans
puis vient l'époque où il veut voler de
ses propres ailes
un emprunt d'un million et demi d'euros
pour ouvrir son propre restaurant dans
le centre ville de saint trop
les remboursements deviennent trop lourd
ils passent très proche du ravin il
tente une nouvelle expérience à paris
qui se solde par un échec les leçons de
la vie forge son caractère il vend son
talent aux plus riches le jeu le luxe
vite dans tous les jours mais je le
touche mais je le vis pas
personnellement j'ai pas de métaux de
luxe je veux j'ai une vie très simple
tout mon argent il est remis dans les
cuisines il est remis j'investis dans
les hommes
[Musique]
l'un des investissements dont il est le
plus fier c'est ce restaurant où les
saveurs du monde se déguste autant
qu'elle se regarde
cette seule cuisine lui a coûté cinq
cent mille euros l'entreprise christophe
leroy compte aujourd'hui 58 salariés
permanents dont six chefs cuisiniers
auxquels s'ajoutent une trentaine de
professionnels extérieurs prêts à
intervenir à tout moment
je pense qu'il ya pas de secret on peut
pas demander beaucoup aux gens je leur
demande de de réagir rapidement ses on
est quand même dans les affaires
saisonnière dont qui sont bien rénumérés
un chef de cuisine gagne à peu près
entre vingt et vingt-cinq mille francs
par mois en fonction de la personne net
et quel que soit le cuisinier chacun
vend son savoir-faire du fait-main façon
haute couture
ici une interprétation française d'une m
une spécialité de la maison
un dessert fourrées au chocolat prêt à
tremper dans une petite sauce caramel
aux graines de sésame
il est minuit cette apparente quiétude
va être bouleversée une commande vient
d'arriver il faut organiser un repas sur
un yacht pour le lendemain midi
christophe leroy lance l'alertent auprès
de ses équipes france et moi je sais pas
où tu es faut que tu me rappelles
d'urgence cahier un bateau qui vient de
tomber pour demain midi il faut qu'on
voit les équipes je rappelle moi savoir
qui va s'occuper du matériel il faut
tout de a à z les boissons et tout donc
je vais appeler mes j'appelle tous les
côtés rappelle moi vite une réunion de
tout le personnel
dès 9 heures du matin heure après il
faut tout lancé en urgence il faut
imaginer la stratégie et la fouille
allez les gars et à 11h30 photo et le
camion thierry une idée qu'est ce qu'on
a qu'est ce qu'on a produit là qu'on
peut avoir tout de suite je cueille
système de classes sous la scène croate
pour 30 personnes
d'accord on prend les petits bols
tartare de saumon dans la feuille de
paye des bananes on y va me la
répartition des rôles est enfin réglé
d'accord n'est pas le mal de mer non
[Applaudissements]
la fête a commencé à bord du queen sauf
un joyau de 40 mètres de l'eau un
milliardaire américain a décidé de
réserver une petite surprise à cm2 de
ses yachts lui servent de salles de
réception à christophe leroy et son
équipe de réussir la fête maintenant du
groupe de musique à la couleur des
nappes
aucune fausse note n'est tolérée
si l'argent dépensé facilement permet de
pousser plus loin les limites
la contrepartie une exigence absolue à
laquelle christophe leroy demandent de
se conformer avec lui on n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur
eh ben c'est à dire que tout est parfait
de la tenue des chaussures cirées les
cheveux coupés et ensuite après pour le
service le tip top
comme dans un quatre étoiles la
gastronomie de haute qualité avec un
service de prestige c'est une marque de
fabrique dans le restaurant où sur un
yacht la prestation doit rester
identique d'une cuisine de 100 mètres
carrés le personnel s'adapte et se
contente d'un espace d'à peine 4 mètres
carrés sur le pont supérieur
les plats se succèdent et quand on aime
on ne compte pas
j'ai déjeuné magnifique nous habitons à
new york et nous avons fait le tour du
monde mais heureux ce matin
ce repas est fantastique pourquoi parce
que les ingrédients sont pas de vis est
toujours plus loin toujours plus
toujours plus cher toujours mieux quand
je rencontre un client j'essaye toujours
de savoir combien il peut dépenser ce
qu'il a envie de dépenser et jusqu'où il
peut aller
et mon idée de challans mené au maximum
et en fonction de ça lui redonne juste
possible
et aujourd'hui c'est 25 personnes qui
ont travaillé pour servir votre sac
ouvert
ça fait un peu cher son c'est pas bon
marché
de quoi donner le sourire 800 euros le
couvert sur ce yacht contre 200 euros en
moyenne dans son restaurant
le déplacement valait manifestement
l'appel les fêtes tropézienne n'ont pas
de limites
christophe leroy non plus c'est bien
pour cela qu'en hiver il se rapproche
des sommes à avoriaz il dirige cet hôtel
depuis deux ans la station a voulu
redorer son blason et faire appel au
savoir faire d'un grand chef et surtout
à sa notoriété
ici aussi il a marqué de son empreinte
la décoration une architecture des
années 70 une atmosphère très tendance à
croire qu'une assiette seul l'ennui il
lui faut à tout prix créer l'ambiance
autour
mais la fête est son obsession de la
servir lui font probablement de londres
aucune étoile ne court-on sa cuisine
pour le moment trop théâtral pour les
uns pas assez classique pour les autres
la haute gastronomie n'a pas l'habitude
de sortir des sentiers battus moi je
veux faire mon métier comme jeune et je
veux pas m'occuper de savoir si pour
avoir une étoile au guide michelin il
faut être ouvert au déjeuner il faut
rentrer dans tel ou tel critère on me
reproche certainement ils doivent
forcément me reprocher de trop dispersé
moi je ne pense pas l'important c'est de
donner du bonheur aux gens et je pense
que j'ai un public aujourd'hui le public
est nombreux
en cuisine douze stagiaires
christophe leroy devient l'attraction
touristique ici sur mon coin fourneaux
j'ai toujours ce qu'on appelle des
bruits en poule pourquoi pour pas que ce
soit trop salée il fait ce qu'il aime
partager son savoir
le cuisinier se transforme cette fois en
professeur 35 euros les trois leçons
coque en est mort son show à 1800 mètres
d'altitude il met en scène les produits
de la montagne
la recette du jour croustillant dollars
et ses petits légumes apparaître son
plaisir révélé ses petits trucs thouars
d'accord expliquez moi madame ce qui
nous intéresse mais disons que je suis
ravie quand fait des cuisiniers les
grands chefs nos joueurs parce que bon
ça pour rester un monde assez secret est
la cible en porte on discute avec que
j'ai refaire la bonne recette
pensez que vous allez y arriver passer
du temps mais elle veut faire cuire
chaque légume individuelles bien
beauxis avait de la journée en kern
essayé de faire après l'observation
vient la dégustation à la montagne comme
à la mer
christophe leroy ne se contente pas de
rester dans son hôtel il a toujours ce
besoin d'oxygène d'aller voir ailleurs
si sa cuisine que créer l'événement ici
les clients ne lui demande pas
d'organiser de fait alors c'est lui qui
leur réservent des surprises
ce soir dîner dans un refuge de la
montagne sans électricité loin des
pistes et du confort de la station
[Musique]
les cuisiniers en vadrouille toujours à
la quête de plus d'émotion à leur tête
un chef qui aime raconter des histoires
surtout quand elles conduisent de plus
en plus haut
tout dîner dehors surtout non chirac
c'est vraiment moche est-ce que vous
avez l'impression vous allez goûter de
la grande cuisine c'est plutôt le
folklore les histoires qui aura en plus
la chronique cuisine que 39,5 en même
temps milliards pas évident ils ont rien
à voir toujours plus étonné sans
décevoir la clientèle exige d'être
surprise
le metteur en fête pour tous alors
davantage ses limites ils installent
l'assiette au centre du spectacle le
goût en parfaite harmonie avec la
couleur locale le jour tout pour mettre
en accord le plaisir de la bouche et
celui des yeux faire vivre cette cuisine
a de quoi épuiser christophe qu'est ce
qui est à la fête c'est oui ce sont les
rouge et vert si c'est pas tous les
convives
ces genres de choses que j'apprécie
avant qu'on le pense que c'est fini mais
on ne prend pas un petit côté visible
quand même pour vous c'est toujours
compliqué m'est arrivé il y avait 50 cm
de poudreuse
c'est quand même de la grande cuisine
la grande cuisine c'est de la bonne
cuisine il n'y a pas ça quand une grande
cuisine il suffit de bien la faire ces
petits jude cochon c'est quoi la
gastronomie sort de son univers habituel
sans oublier de mettre les petits plats
dans les grands
[Musique]